what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel um today I have a
special guest on the channel why don't
you introduce yourself to the people
my name is James Christensen I'm a
father's rights Advocate uh and I like
to use the hashtag how I got custody
okay so what initially got you into
um father's rights
well I was unfortunately dragged into my
own custody battle I had a child out of
wedlock with my daughter's mother my
daughter's now grown and in her 20s now
I was dragged into Family Court well
first I was dragged into a restraining
order court because we have some
conflict in 2001 over me and her arguing
over my right to see my daughter when
she was about three weeks old so because
we're arguing the mother decided like a
lot of women do before they go to Family
Court for a custody battle should try to
get an anti-harassment or a restraining
order against me I was dragged in there
couldn't afford an attorney
attorneys I left I was warehouse worker
who flunked out of college lived
paycheck to paycheck then when it was
time to go to court I couldn't afford an
attorney they wanted five thousand
dollars up front and they told me you'll
get every other weekend and
um so I learned how to fight things
myself and I had a couple of father's
rights Advocates helping me out a little
bit
and then after I beat the restraining
order then we went to Family Court then
she got an attorney and I knew the war
was on and I fought and seven months
later I had full custody of my daughter
and then I started joining a couple
other fathers and non-custodial parents
rights groups and volunteering and the
more I got in contact with people the
more they wanted to hear my story so it
just evolved into me sharing my story
working with people and telling them
what worked for me and I actually
continued to be dragged in and out of
court for the next 18 years off and on
and still being falsely accused even
though I raised my daughter and the
Mother wasn't really involved after that
so then I started you know my own
advocacy
and uh started working with people
one-on-one and it's kind of blown up
since then especially with uh social
media so I've been doing this full time
for about 15 years now
so you mentioned a restraining order
like one thing when I was like starting
to learn about custody is that
restraining orders are really easy to
get right and and a lot of times sort of
at least in the UK they sort of just
freely give those out
yes they they hand them out like water
and um there's been plenty of
documentation writings articles uh
probably the the most popular
documentary hopefully it'll be the
second most popular one after you do
yours um the most popular documentary on
the American family court system
um they have they have a trailer for two
minutes talking about false abuse claims
and how they're just commonly used as a
leverage detective I actually worked at
a couple law firms and have done a lot
of paralegal work for attorneys some
some attorneys actually asked me for
some of my packets when they're starting
off in Family Court which is kind of
ironic I never went to law school but
it's well documented actually there's
two bar associations the one in
California the one in Illinois they've
written articles that say they are very
concerned about the escalating problem
basically the epidemic of women uh
basically women using domestic violence
and anti-harassment protection orders as
leveraging custody battles and there was
actually an article by a Seattle
newspaper called Seattle weekly which I
actually usually share with my clients
and they use it as a reference where the
courts in Seattle were investigated and
interviewed by this Seattle paper
Seattle weekly and the article showed
and interviewed uh uh attorneys
substitute judges called Pro tem judges
and actual judges and they're pretty
much admitting that they hand emergency
restrainment about like water with no
questions because one of the biggest
problems is women can go in emergency
restraint or Court without the other
side and then the other side has their
due process right at a return hearing
two weeks later to undo the emergency
order and what this Seattle week the
article revealed was once they get the
emergency restraint order then there's
momentum like a wave and they're like
well they got the emergency order they
the father probably was scary and
probably did something wrong or probably
abused the kids or her so let's just go
ahead and Grant it just in case
and
um I've talked to countless other people
that hold just in case there is there's
no due process there's no evidence and
the burden of proof in Family Court
that's also a problem is that you go and
get a restraining order and if you
violate it it's a crime yeah you don't
have you don't the typical due process
is rights that you have when you have a
jury trial in a criminal court right you
know a right to a jury of your peers a
right to a public defender if you can't
afford an attorney a right to be heard a
right to confront your accusers most of
these cases now the emergency order is
usually called ex parte a Latin term
meaning for one party the mother will go
into court not give the guy notice say
oh I I don't want to give them notice
because if I tell him they'll be down
here he'll kill me so then they get the
restraining order the emergency one then
you have a return hearing it's called a
show cause hearing when you come back to
court and the dad has a chance to show
cause why she shouldn't get the
restraining order and it might be a five
minute Hearing in front of one judge
among 20 others that day
and nobody gets to really examine and
cross-examine the mother and well where
were you on this night when you said
that he was scary and all this other
stuff and this is where if a dad has an
attorney and he wants to stick with
attorney like I won and hundreds of
others and my clients have won without
an attorney like I did but the attorneys
are in on it too and so
one thing that attorneys why are the
attorneys in on it
well it's the number one thing that I I
believe after dealing with 25
000 cases in 20 years of doing this is
the culture of the entire court system I
can't I there's countless times I'll
talk to a guy who's at an attorney for a
couple months or maybe a year the
attorney says well don't attack the
mother that will look bad in court
the court system is a place where you
confront your Witnesses where you have
oral argument where you have a
competition to Vie for the truth and see
who's going to win but these attorneys
come out of law school they don't know
how to be a lawyer the law firm teaches
them here's the culture of the Court
here's the unspoken rules you don't
attack the mother you don't attack a
guardian litem who's there to
investigate the best interest of the
child and a lot of them are feminists
these judges go to these judges go to
seminars or they say screw the dads due
process rights we're kicking you out
buddy sayonor of goodbye
the judges go to seminars that say that
yeah there's there's all kinds of things
where judges and lawyers uh in some
states they call them Coes for
continuing learning education judges
have breakfasts together where they they
worship each other and they give each
other adoration and they talk about how
great they are or they have a speaker
here and speaker there and they'll talk
about family law issues of the day and
it might be one speaker who's tilted in
their own mindset or again it's the
culture of the system if you think about
like Jim Crow South let's say uh you're
a white attorney defending a black
person who's accused of raping a white
woman or patting a white woman on the
butt in Jim Crow South you're pretty
much toast or before that because the
culture of the Court the judge might be
a KKK wizard Grand wizard the jury is
probably racist and so they'll till A
Time to Kill with Matthew McConaughey
and Samuel Jackson was a great movie
that depicted that it's the culture of
the courtroom because if you have a law
that says do what's in the best interest
of the child decide on whether this
domestic balance based on the low
preponderance of evidence burden you
know in Criminal Court you have to prove
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt way up here
you have no doubt the person did
domestic violence and there's already
domestic violence crimes but to get a
restraining order you have to prove more
likely than not or they call it the 51
49 burden they could believe both sides
but if they believe the woman just a
little bit and they're worried that she
might be a victim of domestic violence
and the documentary that I mentioned
before there's a Harvard law professor
who said domestic violence is defined so
broadly it's easy to say this is
domestic violence go ahead no because I
was just reading um this book about how
they've switched the definitions of like
rape abuse domestic violence like um in
the laws
um the one that I know a little better
is rape like it used to be
um for like basically for sex and now
it's like unwanted like unconsensual
penetration so yeah right so brought
like what is consent like do we need and
and that's right they kind of like
switch like and this is what I realized
during these interviews I'm like they
like add all these words where nobody
knows what they mean and they just add
all these like really confusing words to
like confuse you like then I realized
abuse they started adding in like
um coercive control like what the
does that mean right
I had a girl on my show come in and say
that she was um basically like raped
because she like basically the guy was
being pushy about having sex like she
said no he's pushing it but I'm like by
that logic like if I get persuaded into
buying a car then I've been you know
what I mean right right and then she
changed yeah yeah that I was sales raped
I'm like this doesn't make sense but
they're telling this to the women in the
schools like because they'll tell like
this to the women in the schools that
you need to report them or like like or
this is abuse or like add in all these
words that mean nothing and women
anything so they're just like yeah go
um so it's just very it's very weird
it's very weird well we we actually just
we change the laws out here in
Washington state where I'm in the
greater Seattle area we changed the laws
out here just last summer and they've
defined it even more broadly if you're
driving your car erratically with your
wife in the car that's domestic violence
against her too so
you could be if you swerve to miss a
dead animal on the road and she
interprecially like oh you're just doing
it to to Rattle My Cage that's domestic
violence and there's a
I had a guy accused of assault or um
like coerced it or something and he was
in a wheelchair
actually I actually just I'm like just a
guy hey what do you mean I just I just
work with a guy I actually have a friend
that I used to go to church with about
25 years ago I worked with him through
his divorce the mother accused him of
domestic violence she was scared of him
which is under the broad definition and
so he wrote in his defense paperwork
what are you afraid of me doing doing
donuts in my wheelchair in the parking
lot is that what's going to scare you
you know it was so insane we had to give
an insane response and then they dropped
that because we made her we were able to
turn her words into looking something
very ridiculous but it's the they're
actually the the laws in a lot of places
also are the infliction of of fear of
harm so I had a guy who had a five-year
protection order he slammed the phone
one time because he was mad in an
argument and the mother or the white
ex-wife was afraid that he was going to
do something violent and I'll tell you
this real quick I got custody of my
daughter when she was seven months old
so I got all the things against me that
that the world tells you can't do I had
an infant that I was taking care of I'm
a white male who raised a biracial
daughter and she was seven months old
when I had her full time and I had no
help from the mother she abandoned her
for a year and a half after I won and
then sparsely got involved with her and
stuff like that so guys can do this
stuff but when I went back to court the
mother got a new attorney that was one
of the most vicious family law attorneys
I've ever seen he said racial slurs to
another attorney he lost cases on
purpose for women clients so that they
would go broke and he'd invite them to
live with him and play Hero he was
really crazy and kooky in the bar never
did anything about him and he would
attack people and I had every attorney I
talked to was afraid of this guy and
I've defeated him in the even in the
court of appeals but for 18 years or
about 15 years then he retired he would
call me a monster crazy abusive toward
women and children and I had full
custody of my daughter I was still
discriminated against over and over even
as a custodial father and again it's the
culture of the Court anybody with a
common sense would say why does she
thank you for raising her kid no I get
attacked even when I'm raising the kid
do you think they know and like do you
think they're con like because okay I
have two like sort of theories going
where part of me is like you know how
there's like sort of a subconscious like
discrimination against men just in
society yeah I don't think everybody's
aware of it like I think there's
well-meaning people that don't realize
it
um but on the other hand there are
people that are aware of it and are just
evil man-haters
yes yes yes so what is your profession
of the court system is it more of like
an unconscious bias or is it more of
evil man haters like if you had to pick
I would lean toward the evil man-haters
because they're I think maybe even the
evil man-haters go in with a do-gooder
mentality but a lot of a lot of people
info in the system they come in and they
will be a social worker who maybe got
molested when she was younger and I'm
gonna go Rescue all these women from all
these abusive men and anytime a woman
cries cries wolf they just believe them
and then they go all out and use all
their power and restore this is the
other thing that people get there is an
overwhelming Draconian over-the-top
monstrosity of a system that comes down
against the Dead the judge's bias
against them the mother's attorney is
allowed to crucify him in court like I
said your own attorney is afraid to
stand up because of the culture and how
to look and if you're too aggressive you
got to go in front of that judge next
week on another hearing and they're
they're afraid of the boogeyman so you
got and then you got a guardian item a
psychologist investigator uh uh and
other people who uh the anger management
system that's also filled with men anger
management coaches those guys are total
sellouts to their own gender and they're
just by they assume that dads are
whatever they're called to be and then
on top of that they all have Financial
incentives to keep it going if your
domestic violence uh assessor assigned
to assess where this guy has domestic
violence problems you're not even a
psychologist you might be a social
worker or somebody who just got in there
to say rescue women and you if you don't
finally have a domestic violence problem
you just lost out on the year of
business of domestic violence counseling
so there's a financial motive too but
there there's evil people in there and
then if you go on there kind of like
Washington DC and politics people go to
Washington DC to change the system or
politics and they go back and Washington
DC changes them you walk into this big
old system and you try and look I
actually have somebody who's become a
friend there's one family law attorney I
currently like I've liked about four of
them in 25 years she said that since she
went in trying to do justice in the
system and she thought as a new attorney
she was going to help men and things
like that and she got shot down so hard
that she said the system was against her
the judges hated her because she's
pretty she looks younger than she is and
she comes in acting like she knows it
all according to them and judges don't
like to be blasphemed they get a God
complex so they have their mind made up
if you come in and say well the law says
the best sense of the child is this and
the law says preponderous evidence and
they don't have upon his evidence to
show him a monster and here's pictures
of me with the dog I had a guy who
um I was talking with him I've been
working with him for 15 years when he
had his first baby with the mom she let
him have the baby overnight once a week
but said give the kid back so I said why
don't you file in court and just keep
your daughter he's like what I can do
that I'm like yeah there's no Corridor
so he served her paper when it was time
for him to give the kid back on a
Saturday after an overnight he served
her paperwork he hopped out of the car
his dad hopped out of the car served her
paperwork they thought she was gonna he
was gonna bring the baby back
he's brought her papers she lost her
mind called the cops the cops did a
welfare check her dad who she lived with
was cussing out the baby's dad and then
she went to court and said he was
touching the child inappropriately
applying too much diaper rash kissing
around the mouth all this stuff she just
got done letting him have the child
overnight but when she went to court
there goes those false allegations to in
hysteria to make him look bad and it
didn't make any sense because she just
let him have the kid and she's basically
accusing him of being a molester so
people are allowed to get away with
those false allegations no matter how
ridiculous they are well and I'm to the
point don't believe women ever I think
when I first started when I first
started the show you know I would girls
would come on and say they were abused
raped whatever and then like someone in
the comments was like no no keep asking
them questions so then I would ask like
okay he abused you what specifically
happened and it was like well I refused
to leave his house and he pushed me out
and I'm like well
they'll block the door they'll stand in
front there's guys who've been found who
committed domestic violence who were
defending themselves and pushing them
off because they were getting attacked
or staff I had a guy who had a
protection order against him and he had
pictures of bite marks on his back
there's no way he was attacking her and
she bit him on the back and then he
fought and fought it took him months to
undo that and then when he undid it he
got 50 50 custody but the laws in
Washington state where he was they say
if they make a finding that you have
child abuse or domestic violence it's
mandatory to put restrictions on you but
if a woman does it and they even find it
to be true they give her a bunch of
slack and there's actually plenty of
data out there that shows that women
commit domestic violence at least 15
percent of the time and that's just the
reported stuff there's there's a
bibliography by a guy named Martin
feibert who was a professor and a
psychologist and he has a bibliography
of like hundreds of studies and
interviews compiled and the reporters
stuff that he found was 50 and a lot of
government agencies say women commit
sixty percent of physical abuse and I'm
convinced they commit 95 percent of
alienation guys usually don't play games
they don't got time for the drama I'm
gonna withhold the kid and I'm playing
it now there are some guy dads out there
who are sociopaths and narcissists who
do that but that's the ones who get an
attorney and they railroad a good woman
who's trying to work with him and they
railroad that lady because he has a new
lover or he hates her or whatever but
the vast majority of of abuse of of this
psychological and emotional abuse now I
saw you on one a podcast saying you know
guys should be women should be charged
with a crime with holding a child
because and I totally agree because it
is Criminal because you are depriving
the child of a basic life need and a lot
of my videos I ask people to think this
is this is what the problem is the
system is the the culture of the system
has everybody brainwashed and there's a
there's a momentum of it so when you
want to think you want to stand up and
say something you're just you're just
Avalanche with this stuff so you don't
even think about it so I have guys pause
and think outside of like this this
example outside of food Water and Air
what's the most important thing in a
child's life it's meaningful loving
significant relationships with both
parents and all the data even shows like
you've said other people have said that
went single custodial dad homes have
better statistics than than single
mother homes because a lot of them are
just there for the kid because of
welfare and child support and they don't
have a sense of protection like a guy
and a guy brings something that a woman
can't possibly give which is male
affirmation that forms an identity and
confidence for Life the breastfeeding
and nurturing in the toddler years only
goes so far the male affirmation and we
see it in movies even in the cartoon
Lion King when Simba went back and
fought his uncle for his kingdom back
yeah his father said remember who you
are like know who you are and that's
another problem I deal with the men
they're scared to stand up to the women
and like you said there's some conscious
feminism in the culture you you watch TV
or commercials the dumb person in the
commercial is the husband if you even
when you watch The Cosby Show when
there's a controversial period of time
Claire Huxtable puts her foot down and
Bill Cosby is like okay dear you know so
there's all this subtle stuff that makes
us think we can't stand up to a woman
and men are taught to protect a woman be
a gentleman all this stuff and it's
blessed me to say this is the vicious
Wicked Woman who's abusing the children
and manipulating them for leverage or
and and for the house the home I know
women who plotted it out from the
beginning to get a guy I'll be married
10 years I'll get a retirement
I'm seeing text proving that and she's
still got custody I was like what the
hell like right and even even like they
lie sometimes and they just like brush
over and I'm like what
I actually had a client this woman came
to court she would serve paperwork for
and he tried to get a responder first
and beat her to the punch I think it was
and then emergency custody and then she
was a no-show for court a couple times
then she came to court and said I'm not
ready and I'm a victim and they said
well once you serve paperwork ahead of
time she goes no and then the and
he said are you sure because the judge
had a proof of service in front of him
now sometimes the judges do get fair or
are objective but he had a proof of
service from the process server in front
of him and he goes I'm gonna give you
one more chance to clear to to answer
and she says no I didn't get served and
then the father had a picture and some
extra evidence he goes and the judge
said you just got caught lying why did
you lie to me and she goes I didn't
think it mattered like these women don't
think perjury matters because there
there is no prosecution for perjury
nobody cares well can I also say they
don't talk about verbal violence against
men like because a lot of times when men
react it's because women have pushed
them so far I saw a video of this woman
you know um taunting a man about his
dead son
talk to him saying oh like oh yeah
there's a reason he like just just
haunting him and then he he he hits her
who abused too I'm like come on right
I'm not saying you should hit it shake
but like what did you happen
and most guys use restraint over years
for that and then at some point you just
snap I mean we know about psychological
torture and stuff you know that when you
have a prisoner of war you tie them up
and you put a drop of water on their
forehead and you do it slowly and that's
no big deal after the first 20 minutes
but then you will go nuts after that and
it's drip after drip of your you know
you're a punk your little you're a
little this and your mama this and
you're and over and over again if a guy
did that to somebody that that's
fighting words the first round of you
saying that well and and they train the
women in the schools to like think
everything's abuse too they do I I went
to um a college like that it was like
one of the first like colleges to let
trans people in the dorms not that that
has anything to do with the the man
stuff but just to get the idea of where
the head space was at school right and
literally they sat us down and we're
saying like if you change your mind
during like like if you wanna
um basically if you consent to sex and
then he pushes it I think you say no no
and then like like a car salesman I'm
like what do you expect from the men
they wanted the smash like right and so
and then you switch your you change your
mind then now you have been raped like
that is a form of rape they tell this to
the women and you are a good person if
you come forward and like
so it's like what why are they telling
them that
why are they and the better like and so
I'm like this is open missandry where is
the men if the what if vice versa
happened why is it only men right like
women push it I've seen women go to
um literally like women go to like um
events of high-end athletes or whatever
trying to get them to cheat on their
wives I've never seen seen a coercion
campaign for those men right right right
right and and some of those guys need
some I think you know
I I have some I have some friends who
are um athletic athletic Trainers for
people who are you know going to the Pro
Football Draft and things like that I'm
thinking about talking to them and say
hey I'll talk to your guys for free
about what's going to happen when they
become pro athletes and stuff because
these guys need a serious wake-up call
and even with books out there about this
this woman is telling people how to trap
dudes and stuff like that the guys still
are oblivious because they're caught up
in the moment you know guys sometimes
they can't like I'm a traditionalist you
know my daughter's mom I you know I was
I was a virgin later in life I'm I'm a
God believer and I I'm believing in
traditional marriage but there's the
reality of human nature for the average
person also that I'm realistic about and
you talked about the culture stuff I
didn't I went into this just thinking
the same stuff that Society tells me for
the most part and then when I got in
there I got a dose of reality and I
walked into court and they're treating
me like I'm a monster and even the
bailiff is talking crazy to me in my
first hearing and so there's it's just
this culture that's overwhelming I
personally believe there's a spiritual
war behind it because God's design is
the the father is the protector in the
head and everything in this world is
there's evil entities and people that
are fighting against tradition and the
right thing at all all at all times and
Men we're drama-free we're laid back
sometimes we're just lazy so here comes
the feminist movement like oh that's
great for them you know I don't want any
drama I don't want to deal with them and
next thing you know they're take just
like you know if if you're in a
negotiator if you if you have an enemy
like let's just give you a little bit of
land and appease you they'll encroach on
you and like Hitler wasn't going to stop
or bad people don't stop and we let our
guard down and now they totally dominate
yeah well
and and and if all these courts cared
about the best interest of the child
give the kid to the men
right I mean if if the results are
significantly better give the men
custody and the crazy thing is I realize
that a lot of the courts like the way
they phrase it is like who spent the
most time with the child but I'm like
okay so we want the men to protect and
provide for their families and then we
punish them for doing it I'm like if
he's gone he's doing what he's supposed
to do working right no just you know but
like the average guy go ahead
right but there's a few different things
with that because the law is very when
you say what's the very best interest of
the child the law is written vaguely
intentionally sometimes because they
don't want to lock things into one thing
in any area of law for the most part
except criminal law they're very
specific about what's a crime and you
know except rape is vague anything is
they feel is right but but the best
sense of child is vague so what's the
best interest in the child it's whatever
you argue it is and the science is
overwhelming
and the data is clear that when and this
is where people get stuff wrong I hear
people announce all the time when the
father's not involved you know every 95
of people in prison didn't have a father
involved what does that mean if you look
at a lot of the statistics
um it's when the father's not in the
home full time and people say well the
father needs to be involved so we'll
give the kid we'll give him every other
weekend because he's probably working
that's a cultural thing that's uh you
have and the other problem with the
judges they're just some doofus dork who
was fed a Golden Spoon their whole life
their their mom and dad stayed married
and then they go to law school they
don't know anything about anything they
went to Yuppie parties they went to frat
parties and all of a sudden they're a
lawyer and then they become a judge and
they're just following along with what
everybody else says and they don't know
they don't have any real life experience
with this and then they frown up
everybody has baby mama drama is some
second class peon and they're this
Aristocrat Superior self-righteous God
complex having judged who knows it all
but they don't believe what you just
said this is why I tell dads you have to
go into the courtroom and overwhelmingly
unbrainwash the judges tell them the
stuff like you judge think about outside
of food Water and Air what does a child
need both parents equally involved at
the very least and this woman is driving
the child of me and it's not about me
versus her as much as what does the
child need if that if that woman gave
the child water but not food or vice
versa we would have CPS on our she be a
child abuser she's depriving the child
of the next most important thing and
then I tell judges if you release the
child into society you're a public
servant if you release a child into
society and give the mom Total
Domination control after her alienation
and manipulation and withholding the
child you are releasing a dysfunctional
child into society you have a duty of
care responsibility to society to not
release such kids and decide you're
going to destroy our society every
single supposedly there's a bunch of
mothers out there every single
politician Pastor Advocate you know they
say Dad step up to the plate be involved
like you kind of said earlier and then
here goes the court the only and this is
how I put it even though the culture is
the way it is I'll tell the judge look
everybody is saying be involved the
statute like in California there's a
statue that says the legislature deems
it important for both parents to have
intimate involvement with the child and
then they don't they don't rule in that
way so I would say the legislature
pastors politicians everybody there's
women out there crying for fathers who
step up and they're because there are
some deadbeats but it's rare and here we
are in court and the only person in the
entire world that doesn't want me to be
involved with the child is this woman
over here
I no longer believe in deadbeat dads I
like I decided this the other day I
think they may exist but I think most of
them I'd be dads are just women like men
that are just like well I have to fight
in court to see my kids it I'm just
gonna go because every cat I know has
had a horrible situation and I don't
want to pass money I'm not gonna fight
for this so if she wants to not let me
see my kid I refuse to be at her beck
and call for a lifetime
um
can I can I say something real quick
before I forget and I'll forget but
Harriet Tubman said she could free a lot
more slaves if if they knew that they
were slaves there's a bunch of guys who
I know could get full custody 50 50. if
they just grew a pair and fought despite
everything that they hear but they don't
want to or they're afraid of the
Boogeyman and they go to one hearing and
guess I got slapped down five times or
four times in court it took me two and a
half months to get my first visitation
order then I got the mother found in
contempt then eventually I wore her down
where she surrendered it's 95 of court
cases settle out of court and the guy
surrendered so quickly it's easy for the
mother it's like a bully who takes your
lunch money to school but you stand up
to the bully you might have a fight on
your hand but they're not going to want
to keep doing that if guys were just
I've had cases where guys stood up one
time and the mother all of a sudden
surrendered because she couldn't deal
with the guy standing up to her if we
just stood up we changed stuff so how
does a guy do that like the average guy
makes I think forty thousand dollars a
year most people have six months of
savings so they're going for and they're
thinking wow this this whole system is
stacked against me I don't have money
how do they get custody
first of all
well I got full custody without an
attorney and I wasn't even I nobody told
me this is the way that you do it all I
knew is that I was fighting for my
daughter if I lost every hearing I'm in
court fighting for her until she's 18. I
have my mind made up this is a war I'm
going to rescue my daughter most guys
don't have that mindset and I have to
unbrainwash them into that I've held I
stopped counting at 300 the number of
guys who got full custody without an
attorney that I've worked with and they
all did the same thing they got on the
offensive and they went to war now some
of them did their own trials this
information is out there just like about
anything else out on the internet you
know when I've worked with guys
and sometimes I've worked with women who
are getting screwed too but when I work
with guys I've had guys put on two three
four day trials by themselves against
veteran attorneys because they prepped
with me for a few weeks or a month or
two before trial they got a couple
hearings on the bill built a conference
like this isn't as as intimidating as I
thought it would be you know I still get
nervous just like any athlete gets
nervous for a game but I went in I had
like 40 hearings over the course of 18
years so I I convinced guys that it's
not as bad as made out to be you've got
nothing to lose if you surrender now
you're not going to be at the kid's life
for 18 years why don't you fight and
most of the time like I said when guys
get on the offensive and learn this
stuff everything that they need those
guys need good you mean get on the
offensive like what does that mean well
instead of going to court like this is
what guys the mother will come to court
and say he's a monster he's the best
perpetrator is abusive he was abusive
during the relationship 20 years ago he
slammed a phone and so I'm scared if he
got on the fence and say she's a
pathological liar she was suicidal two
months ago she she was saying she's
gonna blow the you know kill herself
then the kids She's mixed pain pills
with alcohol their attorneys will stifle
them and tell them don't even accuse her
of of the stuff that will help get you
custody because so they're held back
from even accusing or confronting their
accusers oh because they they want you
them to play dirty but you can't play
dirty back basically correct yes that
exactly and that's the biggest
a hurdle if you get an attorney and then
you these attorneys will will give you a
sales pitch like a slick oil used car
salesman they'll say hey this is this
I'll I'll fight a great attorneys
advertise as aggressive zealous advocacy
and fighting for you and then you pay
the five thousand dollar retainer they
might fight at the first hearing and
then after that they're like well let's
just let's just wait and see how it goes
let's have a guardian line of
investigate let's have this person come
in and investigate let's have this other
radical feminist examine you and then
when the report comes out and you get
slammed then the attorney goes to
mediation and they say well there's all
these reports against you you're not
going to win so let's surrender most
attorneys this is the hustle with most
attorneys they'll get the big fat
retainer maybe they'll get another
retainer a couple months down the road
then they'll go to mediation which is a
scam and they will sit down and talk
about what you guys are going to settle
on and they don't have to work hard and
get ready for trial to fight for you you
just settle out of court and they're on
to the next big fat retainer what is why
is mediation a scam
because if you think of is it like
because I thought mediation was like
better because you're avoiding Court
well if the other side has all this
leverage in a restraining order you're
on two hours of supervised visitation
you don't have a lot of Leverage to
negotiate at mediation because you never
got an offensive but here's the thing if
I can like some there's mediation can
range sometimes the court has volunteer
services but most times you're paying an
attorney to sit down between you two and
negotiate the thing is if that if that
woman can settle with you and is willing
to negotiate on something Fair let's say
you want 60 40 and you want half the
summer and you're cool with every other
weekend because you work 60 hours a week
but you want half the summer and
vacations and she says no if she's not
going to agree and you pay a mediator to
watch you guys not agree the whole
mediation was a waste of money if you
can agree all you got to do is call her
attorney or if you've got an attorney
your attorney calls it what do you what
do you want to agree on and in 10
minutes over with mediation is set up so
an attorney will say Hey you give me
your clients for mediation I'll give you
my clients it's a show it's a it's a
moot point it's an extra person watching
you guys talk and they're not supposed
to give you legal advice so and a lot of
them kind of push the guy and nudge them
and Bully them and stuff but they're not
supposed to if they do it right they're
just a referee watching you guys
negotiate and if you could settle you
could have settled the other day but
and going into those negotiations that's
another thing this is a war of attrition
if guys are on the offensive like um
when I when I went to court I got zero
visitation in front of a family law
commissioner some places could have a
magistrate or a low-end judge we have a
right in Seattle in the Washington State
to appeal from a commissioner to a judge
I found out about that I did that the
the commissioner gave me zero visitation
the judge gave me five days a week for
four to eight hours at a time with my
infant who lived down the block two
totally different rulings at the same
court but I kept hammering away the
mother tried to get restrained or I
fought back and bucked her and I exposed
her and I was on the offensive and I
totally destroyed her credibility I mean
it was Common Sense what do you mean
like thought-backed and bucked her like
what does that mean like you brought in
like tax receipts videos yes yes so
every time I've gone to court I have
like 20 to 50 exhibits attached to any
motion or Declaration a lot of these
guys are like guys are like what should
I what how much evidence should I bring
to court I'm like all of it
this is one of the biggest things she
did when she when the baby when the
child was a baby she was breastfeeding
and she said your honor um he could see
the child but only for a couple hours
because she's breastfeeding I said you
know look at exhibit 14. there's a
picture of me bottle feeding the child a
couple weeks before we had this conflict
a picture is worth a thousand words I
destroyed her credibility with a picture
she was lying that she didn't share
breast milk or pump
uh so I if if you have it's just like a
ward when you go off to war if you have
a machete a a pistol a bazooka and all
this and grenades you may not use every
weapon when you go off to war but you're
gonna use one or two of them and when I
destroyed her when I got her found in
contempt for violating my quarter
visitation I had like 35 exhibits but I
only used two of them I caught her
attorney off guard he was fumbling
through the paperwork he couldn't find
what I was even talking about I did a
little trick where I flagged and tagged
so you can come you can almost come more
prepared because these attorneys are
only half-assing all these cases anyway
that's exactly one of the major reasons
why you're better off representing
yourself is because they're juggling 20
other cases they can't memorize your
case I didn't need to memorize my life
when I won some hearings I thought oh
yeah I got this exhibit and then I said
your honor they said this but she said
this in the transcript from our last
hearing and he doesn't have it memorized
correct oh I see I had him and the
guardian light and walking out crying
we flunked out of college just destroyed
them in court so what are what are the
common like things that the wife will
accuse him of and how can they like
combat it like what are what are the
most common like what what should a guy
sue a guy she's not letting him see the
kid what should he be ready for like
step one you're going to court well well
when you go to court I I say first of
all it's you start with the law you get
familiar with the law and what it says
and you argue the law to your side like
the best things a child is really big
there actually Florida has their statute
61.13 it starts off the best interest of
the child and here's the factors the
court has to consider and I you tell you
could tell the judge because the judge
is under the law your honor you have to
consider this the number one factor in
Florida is which parent is more willing
to facilitate a meaningful relationship
with the other parent she totally flunks
that factor because she's been
withholding the child from me for this
period of time for no good reason and
then at this period of time she says
that I'm abusive toward the kid well I
got this text message from a couple
weeks earlier saying what a wonderful
father I am see you just pile it on no
no and it's it's not I got I'm telling
you bro it is not that complex it is
it's a lot of work like organizing your
exhibits because you're writing a book
for the court and you have to organize
and try to make it as easy as possible
for them to flip through and read it
that's the hard part is the time and
guys like they get together their stuff
and they get frustrated like oh forget
this I got to get to work tomorrow I
just worked a double shift today you
know but it's the time and when I went
to war with my baby's mom it was going
to work eating and it was my case
sometimes it's like that but if guys
just gave
half the effort I gave and guys who have
won before we would flip the court
system upside down if guys took all
their cases to trial the course would be
overwhelmed the other side bullies you
into surrendering and 95 of court cases
are settled out of court any kind of
lawsuit in criminal cases everybody cops
a plea and if they didn't have the plea
bargaining system they admit they
wouldn't be able to prosecute all these
cases so if you are getting on the
offensive and you lose a hearing you do
a motion for reconsideration if you lose
that then you do a mini appeal you do
Discovery you send her questionnaires
you do a deposition if you have an
attorney I have a video on my YouTube
channel the number one tour weapon is a
deposition where you get to grill the
mother in the lawyer's office with a
court reporter putting them on an oath
it's like a scrimmage before the game
you get all of her testimony and it's
more casual so it's not as stressful and
you get to grill the crap out of her 99
of attorneys don't even do that when I
worked at one Law Firm we used to do
that they would plot a case like okay we
got a case with this that and that let's
do an emergency order and then we're
going to do a double position on the
father within a couple weeks and we're
gonna do this and that most attorneys
don't do that
so there's a lot of tools and weapons
available on top of you just with the
number one tool is your own pair of
testicles and growing some balls and
getting on the offensive and not being
afraid to blaspheme the mother and I
went to court pointing the finger attack
when I first went to court the mother
and Oliver goons the mother actually
brought in an ex-girlfriend of mine that
she hated to testify against me just a
few weeks before that hearing she said
she wanted to kill her and she's a star
witness when we come to court and then
her sisters are there and some friends
are there I'm outnumbered seven to one
and I schooled her because I was focused
on I I liken it to like an Indiana Jones
movie there's a tunnel there's spikes
there's a boulder coming after me and at
the other end of my tunnel is my
daughter I'm going for it I don't care
and most of the the the tunnel that's
dark and it has you know criminals and
Thugs and and Vipers and spikes most of
it's an illusion because it's not as bad
as people think it is they see it and
they back down but my daughter's at the
other end of the tunnel I'm going for it
I have nothing else what's more
important in life to do but go for go
for that and it turned out that
mentality was the number one thing that
I needed because and then you also have
pictures and texts like you said a
picture's worth a thousand if I go to I
went to court and I said look I'm a good
father I'm committed I'm devoted I have
pictures of me holding my daughter my
daughter looking at my face and looking
in my eyes
if I tell them I'm a good father she
said I'm a bad father they're going to
believe her if I show them in pictures a
picture is literally worth a thousand
words in court so dads if you got
conflict with your baby's mom or your
wife make sure you're taking pictures
where you are doing parenting
responsibilities and functions taking
pictures and giving them a bath clipping
their nails brushing their hair taking
them to the park you want that for
memories anyway it's it's when I did in
2001 I had a camera that I had to go to
a photo place and pronounce you guys got
cell phones it's way easier than ever to
do this yourself
right so it's kind of just
so it's like the the system it's just
like normal and they just kind of expect
men to roll over and when you don't you
just become their worst nightmare
basically when you they realize you're
not going away
yeah and and and if if you attack the
attorney the attorney has multiple they
have their oath rules of professional
conduct the oath of an attorney
um and other ethical obligations when
they cross the line and they go to court
and lie they're not supposed to even
help somebody like they're supposed to
thoroughly investigate a case before
they sign off sign a piece of paper and
if you go in there and attack and say
they're lying they're helping this
person then they attack you like how
dare he blasphemy me I've never seen
this before and if everybody got in
there and did that then the system would
change if if attorneys ran against
corrupt judges and while they're running
they said this person get I've seen
cases where a judge will give custody to
a mother who lives with a registered sex
offender who is a heroin drug dealer and
the dad has when he was a teenager he
had a trespass
and they say well just don't leave the
kids alone with the registered sex
offender boyfriend and I've seen actual
cases like that I tell the media about
this stuff they don't want to report on
it I just interviewed a guy where um
where that happened and the the step dad
like touched the daughter and she still
has to live with the
um
like in the house he owns like
technically he's not allowed like the
the guy's not allowed to be in the house
but he still owns it
how is this legal like if it was vice
versa they would not well if if a guy is
even accused of even possibly
potentially being a problem or abusive
toward the kids he he verbally abused
the kids because he yelled at them to go
to their room after they're talking
crazy to the mom so she they they they
use that as leverage and there's
documentaries out there where there's
lawyers admitting that lawyers will tell
people to make it up like I said earlier
there's been articles in Bar Association
published journals that say that and I
tell people I talk I have a packet that
that has all these things uh you know
I'm not trying to sell anything I'm
sorry a bar Associated published
journals wait say that again
um so like the Illinois Bar okay without
a journal or a weekly or monthly
newsletter there's articles published by
attorneys with opinions on the latest
and greatest here's the internet there's
a there's uh new Innovations with the
internet as far as lawyering and
software to help destroy fathers here's
this and that and they'll talk about the
latest goings-on and there's been a
couple articles in Illinois an Illinois
Bar journal and the family law section
of the California bar wrote articles
about the trend of women falsely using
domestic violence protection orders as
leverage so it's this stuff has been
documented by lawyers themselves it's
going as time to go into court and I've
seen lawyers walk out of court and the
law firms I've worked at they say man if
that if the dad did that he'd be in jail
they all admit it as soon as they walk
out of court but they won't say it in
court when it counts that's like a coach
and a football team saying man that was
a bad call by The Ref I can't believe he
did that why didn't you throw the flag
for instant replay you know that's like
after the ball game complaining that and
then attorneys won't go in the attorneys
could change the culture if they all
went in there and fought for guys but
they're not going to do it I I the the
one attorney I like she said that
there's this judge at the courthouse in
in the Seattle area that all the
attorneys hate she's totally incompetent
ignores the law does her own thing don't
tell me what the law is I'll figure that
I know that just give me the facts your
case and she says 10 she knows 10
attorneys who hate that judge and say
why don't they file complaints to the
commission on judicial conduct and she
said they don't want to because they got
to be in front of her another day but if
they all got her disciplines she would
get her act together it's just it's this
Twilight Zone like psychotic paranoia if
you stand up for justice you'll be shot
down
it's like it's like it's like the the
guy who defends the black guy and Jim
Crow South he's not just worried about
all the pressure and you know from every
the jury the prosecutor and the judge
who are all on the Klan he's worried the
Clan's going to come after him and if he
defends this guy or whatever you know so
it's like it's that's it's not the exact
same thing but it helps paint a picture
like these guys are just worried it's
peer pressure from middle school on an
adult level it's insane so what
okay so the guys they have to go on the
offensive get basically every piece of
evidence of you being a good father and
her being a bad mother
yes
no the facts of your case inside and out
yes keep appealing keep going to court
I'm just trying to like break it down
for a guy that's trying to go to court
right now okay so the simple way of
doing it every time somebody attacks you
you attack back and you accuse him of
everything that they factually have done
wrong like in Washington state factors
include this is a child who's performing
parenting functions who could
potentially perform them so if I got
pictures of me bathing my kid in the
sink when they're an infant and most
guys do this and nobody ever talks about
this when after the woman gives birth
he's up in the middle of the night while
she's recovering cleaning up throw up
changing diapers feeding the child or
whatever and if you have pictures of
that stuff you were gonna like I had
pictures of me handling my infant child
and the core was like wow this guy is
intimately involved in everything I had
receipts when I went to court of stuff I
bought above and beyond I gave the
mother money when she was pregnant when
I didn't have to anything that and most
guys overdo it actually because they
think this is my child they're like
they're like they're like a lion with
the with the pride I protect everything
in here and even if a guy is a jerk and
not perfectly ethical there's something
in a guy that says protect what's mine
and that is the most important thing for
a kid in certain vulnerable years and
you have evidence of that you have
pictures of you being there and
protecting and holding your child and
and being involved and stuff so anytime
they attack you you attack back but I I
tell guys once they call me if they call
me before the case gets started guys who
have gotten on the offensive and they
attack the other side and they went for
full custody and didn't stop eventually
they got 50 50 or some of them got
custody because they got on the
offensive if they Blindside you kick you
out of the home you don't have access to
anything you're behind the eight ball
and you got this restraining order now
you got two hours of supervised
visitation and the supervisor is a
radical feminist if if she jumps on you
first there's a little bit of Leverage
there and you got to overcome all that
now it can be done with the stuff I'm
talking about keep fighting keep
appealing keep asking for another motion
and change stuff or eventually the
mother is going to slip up when she's a
pathological liar
but if you get on the offensive from the
beginning right away
then you you up the odds of you doing
better because it's this leverage game
whoever's got the most Leverage The
Other Side is going to surrender when it
comes time to mediate like I said that
happens 95 of the cases and court is a
war so I talked to guys here and what
will happen is like basically they'll
come home one day they don't even know
their wife wants to divorce them and
they're kicked out of their own house
because they get their restraining order
now they don't have access to their kids
they have to wait to go to court often
like six months to a year
uh they already the girls are already
equipped because they get a free lawyer
here if they accuse a guy of abuse
essentially
um so like in that case he's not
prepared like how could he prepare for
something he didn't know was gonna it
it's just like if it's like if if
Germany starts World War II all over
again and they bought they and they bomb
you right and if you're not ready for
the war you better grab a gun and fight
his killer be killed his fight or flight
mode and it's time to get on defensive
and if guys do that and they chip away
and chip away like and they undermine
the mother's whole premise like look she
lied about this look at the studies look
at the bar journals look at all these
articles about I've had guys countless
guys who fought off the restraining
order because they defended themselves
and they use these materials and stuff
that I talk about some of the stuff is
free I have free links to some of this
information and then I have packets
where guys will defend themselves and
cite all this stuff so when you tell a
judge that all your peers and lawyers
are saying women lie about this all the
time you get it you get it you can
convince them more than you can say oh
she's just lying and it's just me versus
her your own peers are saying that she's
doing this and so when there's a
restraining order like that Most states
in in America and I've dealt with people
in Europe before but only a few times
and there's different rules and
different uh jurisdictions but most of
the time when women go get the emergency
restrainer There's an opportunity to go
back and undo it immediately without
having to wait for that hearing three
more six months down the road so that's
called a motion to quash guys should
jump on that and their attorneys don't
tell them about that and then a lot of
times in most places in the states like
we talked about you get the emergency
order ex parte for for one party without
telling the other side and you go do
emotional costs hey they were supposed
to give me notice there's no danger here
that that that they proclaimed with a
reason to not tell me about this there's
no danger so they lied and they got this
bogus thing I want to get it quashed and
undone and they might at least say okay
well you just can't talk to the mother
but you can see the kids and that's a
little inching back and fighting back
and punching back then by the time the
hearing rolls around she's a
pathological liar look at all these
studies look at all this data look at
all these pictures there's text messages
they're saying you're a wonderful dad I
love you and then next week I'm a child
molesting monster domestic violence
perpetrator this is insane you can't
possibly believe this your honor and you
make the judge feel stupid if they rule
in her favor and then if you lose that
you do a reconsideration then you do
another one and then you do a mini
appeal and then you do Discovery just
for starters and they can they can like
subpoena the text messages right like
they can make it so we like they can go
through her phone and stuff
well that some of those subpoenas are a
little bit tricky and tough but when you
have an attorney they have subpoena
power that um that they're able to get
stuff a lot more than a self-represented
guy but I actually I was in I was in a
relationship with somebody last year and
I had to get domestic protection order
against herbs so guys can win this stuff
I got a protection against her she
retaliated tried to get one against me
and she lost and lost and lost a couple
times so now I'm suing her for abusing
the system against me there's another
thing guys could do if they want to
while their case is going on sue the
mother for torts or things like
intentional Affliction emotional
distress abuse of the system and getting
on the offensive and using legal weapons
that are available to you and they can't
do without an attorney so that's all
something they can do you could do all
this stuff without an attorney when when
you see somebody representing themselves
without an attorney it's always making
them look like an idiot and they'll show
that one criminal guy who's nuts and he
got the judge to allow him to represent
himself and that's what you see on TV
there's plenty of there's plenty of guys
out there who know more than me but
there's just nobody out there doing what
I'm doing because they're scared of the
backlash it's stressful it's
overwhelming to deal with and having to
tell guys to grow some balls but there's
people out there who have done it before
me and done it after me and you know
they just they just leave the system
because they don't want to deal with it
anymore I have a passion for this thing
so I've hung around despite all the
reasons to quit on this every father's
rights organization dies out after two
or three years for the most part but
they've come and gone go ahead why is
that because that was
um I know we were talking earlier like
why why is the system
like why don't we see laws change to 50
50 custody I know there's like a couple
states that have done it but it's it
seems to be clearly the minority
yeah well because like uh you know
there's radical feminists in the
legislature that won't uh allow like
they were trying to pass a law in
Washington where in Washington after age
four if you're considered the father you
can't undo that so she cheated on you
and that's not your kid you got to pay
child support till they're 18 because
they say somebody's got to pay
yeah so they they try to change there's
a dad who had a kid who was 13 and when
she was when she was 13 the mom said
that's not your dad and then she undid
his visitation but because of the law he
still had to pay child support so the
child was traumatized doesn't have a
relationship with that kid anymore that
was her father her pseudo father yeah
and she thought that was her dad she was
traumatized she had all kinds of mental
health so that guy and his new wife went
to the legislature with some other
people to try and undo that law there's
a radical feminist representative who
said well if we have a law where women
can come back any time our guys can come
back anytime the wit that those dads
will be so mad that that wasn't their
kid they'll commit domestic violence
against the woman so we can't change the
law so they didn't change the law
because of the domestic violence card
that she threw out there but there's
people out there that will block that
stuff but I do want to say something
about 50 50 laws if you have a law
there's about four states out here
Florida just passed a 50-50 law but
there's always that caveat like unless
there's abuse or domestic violence and
if women are already getting custody
based on that claim I'll just use it
even more here Missouri passed a law
where they said presumption of 50 50 and
the court has to consider all these
other factors but if there's abuse and
then at the end it says if the judge
doesn't feel it's an investment child do
50 50 they don't have to use this
consideration
50 laws aren't even really 50 50 laws
because there's the exceptions and the
exceptions are the legal strategy of 90
of the women and then on top of that
there's always got to be other factors
like who's been involved and how much
time and which is crazy because it's a
mother withholds a child she says I'm
the primary caretaker and then she gets
custody in a lot of States but the 50 50
laws they're a great presumption to
start with but you're dealing with a
biased bigoted court that could do
whatever they want and they say I
declare by a proponent of evidence that
I believe the mother that the father is
incompetent or abusive or domestic
violence and they just rubber stamp all
the exceptions the culture of the Court
the heart of the judge the corrupt heart
of the judge is what needs to be fixed
and we have to unbrainwash them and we
have to fight and most of these most of
what you do outside of Court like just
think of an athlete what you do out the
work you put in the gym in in the weight
room in practice and studying film it
shows up on game day it's what you do
outside and the war of attrition of
wearing the other side down and letting
the bully know you're not going to
tolerate the bullying anymore that's
usually what wins it for now but
changing the laws would I mean we had
the constitution in America for a
hundred years after emancipation and
black people were not treated properly
in Criminal Courts where the judge is a
clan you had to change the judge in the
jury's Hearts so right now all the
juries which are one individual judge
some pretty boy who went to law school
who's a do-gooder to rescue all these
women some radical feminists who got
molested by her dad and as soon as she
hears those triggering words she's like
you're going to be restrained from your
kid you have to change the heart of the
rule maker and that's not happening
anytime soon so is that is because
I always I always have people come at me
because they're like you're just
complaining about the problem you're not
offering any solutions
you know I thought repeal the 19th you
know I mean that's right I mean but but
so my question is like what Solutions do
you see like that there could be you
know and I I just changed their hearts
is very broad you know yes so I do have
specific answers to that I just wanted
to answer you real quickly but number
one while the system is corrupt the
answer is for guys to get on the
offensive and fight the way that I
fought and thousands of other guys who
fought and use all the tools available
to you so that's number one and
hopefully you wear them down to settle
out of court on a better deal the
biggest thing is just like with anything
else if somebody has a job and they do a
bad job you complain about it and you
get them disciplined or you fire them
now nobody complains about the judges
because the lawyers are all part of the
same club and they all go to cocktail
parties together and they they might
even go they might even go to the same
wife swapping parties and I've heard
some stories like that too so the these
people are a corrupt group of elite
Aristocrats who think everybody who
comes to court is a bunch of sub-human
peasants and they don't care about them
and they just care about their status
and everything about but if their job is
on the line if if we had in Tacoma
Washington which is the second biggest
city outside of Seattle and Washington
there were two lawyers running against
the two worst judges in that City or
that County
those lawyers wanted to run and oh and
basically overthrow these judges you
know who had been there for 10 20 years
totally corrupt judges feminists hated
men and stuff like that when it came
time for the father's rights groups to
go door to door and tell people why to
vote for these judges targeted voting
groups
the guys never showed up and so those
same judges retain their power and they
had like endorsements from the cops and
the fire department all these people
they partied with and bought their vote
and endorsement from so that would have
up if they would have said these guys
like one of them was one of the judges
who gave custody to the mom with a sex
offender heroin uh drug dealer if they
would have said she specifically does
this
she should be fired or voted out and
somebody should be voted in that would
change stuff if people got on a campaign
now the guy who created the the greatest
doc the guy who created the greatest
documentary up up to now on the family
court system he went to Washington DC to
try and change laws that guy got burnt
out in a year he was trying to do the
European model presumption of 50 feet I
wrote him I told him dude what you're
doing is not going to work he said well
we're going to give it a try it worked
in Europe I said it's not going to work
I've been doing this 12 years it's not
going to work you have to get the judges
he did it I have never seen the guy
heard from him since he made the
documentary he was gone after a year so
if you get the judges voted out or fired
that's the greatest thing or if lawyers
will dis uh complain about them but what
I do what's worked for me is I've gone
out and protested judges at the
courthouse and I will name a specific
case number and I will say this judge
gave custody to this child abusing
monster this judge is a psychotic witch
who hates men and always gives custody
to women
when I've done that and I've Disturbed
their protective bubble that they're in
and they have to go to work and they
everybody at work is like who's this
crazy nut job Guy They'll go look up the
case all the clerks look up the case
like wow that judge did give custody to
a sex offender boyfriend or a mom with a
sex offender boyfriend they don't want
they live in a bubble that's Untouchable
you ever seen like when the news gets in
the judge's face after they let a rapist
out and they rape again that judge stays
silent and it blows over and they're
back in their bubble again if you hound
away at them and embarrass them and
Disturbed I've protested my judge at his
home in his neighborhood and talked to
his neighbors and told him what a
monster he is at work
wow so it's all about getting rid of the
judges that's the way you change the
system essentially that would be that
would be the number one thing the other
long-term thing is to unbrainwash them
because they are they side with one side
all the time if you woke them up and say
you are destroying Society by releasing
kids into single mother homes which has
been proven to be a detriment to kids
look at the science we went through
covert they said believe the science
believe the science why don't you
believe the science judge but nobody
attempts to make a judge feel stupid if
they make a ruling and you know in favor
of the mother about in um so in the UK I
know they have like um protective order
or like gag orders yeah
um and I have men that just come on the
channel they don't give a they're
just like whatever put me in jail
so wouldn't that violate the gag orders
if they're going and saying like this
judge did this and this judge did that
I'm not telling anybody to violate any
court orders or any laws but most family
court cases are public record if there's
a parentage issue they seal the file to
protect the identity of the non-fathers
because they shouldn't have to be the
court if they're mistaken identity but
there was a case where a guy in Ohio he
went to prison for five years because he
defied an order and he talked bad about
a judge on the Internet or out
protesting that case when I tell people
to protest their judge and grow some
balls they say well you'll go to jail no
that guy had an unconstitutional order
to not talk about the judge see these
judges are such thin-skinned little cry
baby little stems if you talk blasphemy
them it hurts their oppressive little
feelings and they they abuse their power
to shut you down we in America we have
the right to redress a grievances to
free speech and talk bad about public
officers and they're supposed to be able
to take it and have thicker skin but in
that case the guy had an order now if I
was him I would have just appealed the
orders being unconstitutional I wouldn't
have defied and said well it's my
Constitution right now he's in jail for
five years because because he should
have been more wise about it but like
like like
um if I was out threatening the judge
when I was protesting at his house then
I would be committing a crime but I'm
peaceful protest and not saying the word
one time he's out on his porch doing
stuff on a laptop because it was during
covid and they do stuff from home and
they basically run hearings in their
bedroom with a fake background sometimes
but the neighbor's like what are you
doing out here this is a family neighbor
how come you're holding that sign
because my daughter's biracial and I
said he hates biracial kids he's a child
abuser and all this other stuff and he
tag teamed me with the mother's abusive
misogynist you know attorney and they're
like how dare you come out I said well
if the judge wouldn't have thrown me in
jail I got thrown in jail one time and I
wasn't even notified of the hearing and
so
um if the judge wouldn't have thrown me
in jail I wouldn't be out here and if
you didn't abuse authority I wouldn't be
out here and then I get a chance to talk
to the neighbors because they're chewing
at me out like he's a great neighbor I
said I'm sure he is Ted Bundy was a
great co-worker before he he murdered a
bunch of women in the Seattle's
University District like Jerry you're
you're you're front for your double life
has no bearing on what you really are
behind closing doors when nobody's
looking so I got a chance to disturb his
bubble and I walked away just fine I
didn't get arrested the judge knows I
was in my free speech right so nothing
happened it's we're scared of the
boogeyman you could at least go to the
courthouse on court property which is
public property and protest and cite a
public record and say this judge now
I've said some crazy stuff about Judges
I told my judge that him and my baby's
mom I brought this in a brief that they
both hate me and they're tag teaming me
and now they're against me even though I
raise a child and I finally figured it
out I date pretty women and you both
have hideously ugly wives and so when I
when I when I had the court hearing the
judge is like well James is up here
mocking our wives and he just moved on
because I saw the the mother's attorney
tell the judge off in open court which
most attorneys are afraid of and I'm
like this judge isn't going to do
anything and I have a right to my
opinion now I wouldn't recommend that
for everybody but that at that time the
fix was in my daughter was about 16 it
kind of didn't matter at that time so I
thought I'd get a jab in and I've done
videos on judges and exposed them and I
post their home address their driver's
license number and a picture of them at
you know or whatever they're public
figures we people like docs politicians
for bad reasons to win a campaign I'm
letting people know here's a perverted
perversion of justice and they're
they're they're your neighbor you should
know about this in your neighborhood
they're destroying Society
wow no that makes a lot of sense because
I was thinking the other day I'm like it
doesn't seem effective to try to like it
almost seems like a losing battle trying
to change the laws but it makes more
sense if you start putting faces to the
people that are making these decisions
yeah and one reason my judge hated me is
because I got him reversed in the court
of appeals and he made a bad decision on
the child support matter and then when I
got when I got the win I emailed all the
judges and bailers to the courthouse and
say Here's the presiding judge in
Seattle the biggest baddest judge in the
whole upper left corner of the United
States and he can't even read child
support laws what what's going on so I
embarrassed him with everybody else so
he had an agenda against me afterward
but changing changing the laws you have
judges who abuse their Authority and
when you win an appeal it's called you
you the court of appeals will find the
judge abuse their discretion which is
crazy because they're basically saying
this judge is abusing power and all
they're doing is reversing him instead
of him getting kicked out so judges will
abuse their Authority and do whatever
they want Thomas Jefferson actually
warned us the the part of government you
need to fear is the judicial branch
because there's no accountability except
to do an appeal and the average person
can't afford an appeal because attorneys
want 20 they want 22 000 to 5 000 for uh
to come on board for a divorce but an
appeal they want 15 to 20 000 because
they got to read the whole file but if
you represent yourself like I did on
appeal then you already have your case
memorized you know what paper you don't
have to even go back and read it again
you wrote it you know what it says so so
changing the laws
if you have like like again a great
example is before the Civil Rights
Movement we had a you know a
constitution that says all men are
declaration independence all men are
created equal they weren't treated equal
in real life they had the culture had to
catch up to what was written on paper
so until the culture catches up these
judges can be corrupt until you call out
a judge or get them fired or you start
unbrainwashing them so number one to
change the system hold judges
accountable by complaints nobody will
complain by getting them voted out and
fired nobody's going to run against the
sitting judge that's the other unspoken
rule among the club you know the judges
were lawyers so they're part of the same
bar association club and and um so get
rid of the judges if you don't get rid
of the judges then you expose them
individually with protests and embarrass
them and disturb their bubble and then
yeah to change the system if every guy
or a bunch of them got in there and
fought the way that I fought and
thousands of others who won you fight
the right way and get on the offensive
and and and unbrainwash them and change
the culture you know that's the harder
long-term goal but in the meantime go
rescue your kid and fight the way that I
fought and get some help like somebody
like me there's a couple other people
out there but not really out there like
I am and give some one-on-one help to
learn how to do this stuff it's not as
hard as it's made up to be I'm a
warehouse worker who flunked out of
college and I'm destroying attorneys
with 17 to 50 years experience in court
they went to law school and I'm
destroying them I could do it the guys
out there could do it too that's really
my message just grow a pair and give it
a try you know
where where can they find the like what
resources do you have for men that want
to get custody
um
they can cut well I'm the only one in
the world uses the hashtag how I got
custody and if you search how I got
custody and type in the word flow
f-l-o-w that leads you to my flow page
that has all my links into one it's like
a link tree
um I got booted off a link to me because
I said some negative things about kovid
so I guess they shut me down so uh
there's a link tree type of setup called
a flow page if you type in flow and how
I got custody you'll find my flow page
which has my store my online store with
packets and a video I need to do more
videos there's free resources like all
the scientific the three best scientific
studies that I know of
and and sets of data that's you could
download that for free everybody should
use that as exhibit one two and three in
any motion or any defense there's
actually a study in Texas where
psychologists
um said 50 50 parenting plans are the
best scenario for kids out of broken
families and that's because dads almost
never get custody he's not he's not
going the all the way with the full
custody but and 100 psychologists signed
off on it you got 101 experts in one
document that you could just slip in as
the exhibit and you got some experts
testifying in court if the other side
doesn't have any extra testimony said
the science is clear the children you
need to at least start at 50 feet you
don't need to love 50 50 law to say
here's what the expert witness says so
there's there's links to that
I give people a sample the chick that
I'm suing for abusing the system against
me and got me for some money and and did
a basically romance fraud on me I'd give
people a sample of how you know my
lawsuits if people want to sue their ex
and then some states in America I have
links to certain links there like
there's a case in Washington that went
to Supreme Court a dad got custody after
the mother had full custody throughout
the divorce if people are in Washington
that's a great case to know because they
found that she had emotional problems
that made it interfered with her ability
to parent because she was dangling the
kids and alienating them so they gave
her him custody at trial so if but the
problem is attorneys never cite that
case even though it's the most important
case for fathers in Washington which is
insane to me so I have a bunch of
resources in that one place and ways to
contact me if they want a one-on-one
they want a one-on-one consultation
which is the best way to learn for your
case where to go from this point because
you know people need customized
one-on-one help even if you got an
attorney I've got guys who got custody
because they talked to me or watch my
videos and they lit a fire under their
attorney's butt and made them do their
job and they got on the offensive and
they got full custody I had a guy just
testified that he did a testimonial he
got custody of his daughter in case you
lit a fire under his attorney some
people are afraid to stand up to their
own attorney right and you're the boss
you're the one paying them yeah
um okay so they would just put in how
how I got custody and then you'll it'll
come up and and the word flow to get to
my flow page that's the that's the first
best resource or if they type in how I
got custody I got free videos on YouTube
and Instagram I I added it up one time I
got fifty thousand dollars worth of
information that attorney wouldn't even
tell you if they charged that for you
you know
I'm gonna
I wanna I wanna put you on some virtual
panels sometimes with these people that
say it's um because there's there's such
a big group of people that are like oh
the men just don't don't fight and it's
just like the the men that don't want to
see their kids
can I jump in I wanted to say that I
forgot earlier but I've dealt with 25
000 cases in 20 years I've met Five Guys
who didn't want to have a relationship
with their kids so there's nothing more
there's nothing better than a first-hand
eyewitness experience all the polls all
the opinions all the experts are full of
crap they all they all just say oh you
just take the men's side you this and I
was like I used to think that deadbeat
dads were a problem but I just can't
it's like I have never had more messages
than about this documentary I get videos
sent to me every day of women's children
like I get and I'm like I don't have
women coming this documentary could be
about women
but I never even had a woman message me
about right right
see that's a great example of dads will
talk about this stuff on social media on
Facebook and they'll message you stuff
they should be taking those things and
using it as exhibits in court but
they're scared to it the attorney says
oh don't put that in there that'll make
her look bad that's your job to make her
look bad you're trying to win yeah yeah
well and I've heard from guys that they
go to court and like the judge doesn't
care
like they'll make her look bad and
she'll have been found to be lying but
the judge just like doesn't care
yeah and that and that's that's true
like the first hearing I got where I
could have got some visitation that
there was a substitute commissioner
who's a lawyer who's on call when a
judge calls and sick or whatever the
commissioner said you're doing a great
job of financial support we have to
investigate you first to give you any
visitation and again I appealed her
decision to a full-time judge and got
five days a week I got four hours four
days a week mom worked four times and
then I got eight hours on Saturday and
then I got the mother found in contempt
and there's lawyers out there who will
tell dads do not do a Content motion and
get her in trouble for violating it
that's your only recourse but I realized
in the UK is the I didn't even know
about the judges like colluding with the
lawyers but what I realized is
the the judges here the number one
clients are the women's shelters
so they win too many cases for the men
otherwise they lose their number one
clients because I'd imagine if you're
winning if you're like making them look
stupid in court all the time where are
you going to get like they're going to
stop sending you clients yeah there's
there's Financial back deals and stuff
like that and that obviously comes in
with in America with title 4D with child
support and actually on the child
support side the deadbeat dad thing is a
myth there also 80 of working fathers
pay child support on time so the the
mothers who are non-custodial mothers
most of the time they'll deviate like if
they're supposed to pay 500 like she's
like oh I'm not working right now oh
okay we'll drop it to the minimum 100
per kid they'll feel bad for them and so
they have low child support amounts or
if they pay child support they have to
pay a regular amount they're late all
the time or they don't pay so the
deadbeat dad thing is a total myth it's
just it's just this cultural stuff like
we worship single mothers and I get I
always tell people presume that that
mother became a single mother because
she pushed the dad out because that
happens 95 of the time well I always say
a red flag is if a girl says she was
abused or raped in the past I know this
is Harsh I know this is Harsh guys but I
I just at this point I'm like I've had
so many women give me these stories and
when I ask like five simple questions
there's no evidence I'm like did you go
to court no did you did you go to
criminal police no call the police no do
you have any like permanent because I'd
imagine if a guy's hitting you because
I'm I'm a supreme athlete like I had Pro
contracts in the fall I can deadlift 300
pounds I can bench about it I am a
strong I'm six foot I'm a strong woman
average guy can beat me up average right
right right Jim I'm losing like there's
not even so this whole idea I'm like if
he's trying to beat you up you would
have permanent
and that's that's actually an argument a
lot of my guys have won because they'll
they'll use that see if you go to court
with one aspect or one argument or text
messages or what you just said the
argument like look at me I'm six foot
four two fifty she's five one 120. if I
really beat her up you on her she would
be broken in half and then you have the
text messages and the pictures you have
to overwhelmingly over prove yourself so
if you pile it on then you have a chance
for the judge go well this one's really
crazy you know the judges might be cool
with dabs as long as you stay in your
lane and you're in every other weekend
you stay there once you start saying I
want 50 50 I want custody no whoa you're
Crossing line just like black people in
Jim Crow South you can have your own
sidewalk your own water fountain but
don't come to ours it's really that kind
of similar type of mentality just just
stay in your lane and we like you you
know and you don't have to go for good
judges you know like because we talk
about single mothers a lot and how uh
men don't want to date single mothers in
general right yeah and I was thinking
I'm like you know if men had full
custody it would probably like the woman
could probably move on with her life a
bit easier and getting like remarried
and stuff because it's a lot bigger of a
commitment for a guy
um like do you know I mean like like the
reason like single fathers don't have as
hard of a time it's like most single
fathers it's like six days a month right
right right I was thinking I'm like even
like even if you're being completely
selfish like it's like it probably would
help you and like re like moving forward
anyways like I don't know why you
wouldn't want the dad to help you right
right and it's crazy because these
mothers they'll they'll choose like like
the the guy just helped him who's in a
wheelchair this judge didn't let him
testify at trial didn't let him bring
Witnesses and stuff and he kind of got a
hold of me at the last minute but the
mom accused him of domestic violence and
she leaves the child with her stepdad
who molested her when she was younger
and these women will have a babysitter a
daycare they'll take a kid to a daycare
when the dad's off of work like why why
isn't it your priority like there's
people I know people out there they hate
each other as far as their dating
relationship but they honor the they
they said I chose to have a child with
you that child needs you I don't like
you but we're going to get along for the
sake of the kid and I love women like
that but like you said the the dominant
women they have this thing like well if
I let them have the kid too much then he
might go back and they literally say
this and I've heard don't he might get
custody I can't get welfare I can't get
housing I can't get this now it's not a
control thing because then I realized I
was like what's like male evil right
when we think like male and female evil
it's like male evil is like I would say
like aggression violence we're female
evil is manipulation and spite right and
I'm like it's basically the government
giving us a smoking like imagine if a
man is the angriest he's ever been in
his life and the government said you can
leave legally kill that guy bar you're
fighting you know where whatever or that
guy whoever made this because whoever
made this man Angry legally and there's
no consequence that's what they're doing
to the women they're saying the angriest
you've ever because when are you angrier
as a woman right right and the
government's saying you can you can
legally make this man's life miserable
it's like when you make it legal a bunch
of chicks are gonna do it right and that
that's a great analogy I've never heard
before like if you if you apply the same
thing to a dude we would think that's
crazy you can't allow that to happen but
here's the other thing is that like I
told you I was like you like before I
went to family court and felt the heat
of it
I thought oh okay the courts do what
they do I've heard some nightmare
stories you know Johnny Carson who did
The Tonight Show for the longest he was
made fun of because he kept getting
divorced and they'd take him for
Millions that's funny but it's
psychologically tormenting to a guy they
build this Empire and you can walk in
and walk out and just take it like think
about Michael Jordan's wife she was a
waitress and she walked away with like
250 million like he built that Empire
all by himself and she got a huge chunk
of it well and what I realized too I was
like
the idea that like women build men is so
stupid because they'll be like oh I
built him I'm like what the you
didn't build Diane right they came
along for the ride why are you inside
like you're not entitled to anything
um
I would go so far I would ban child
support I would ban alimony you wouldn't
get I'm not because well if you
think about it alimony was created
because women in the early 1900s in
America fathers always got full custody
because it was a patriarchal society you
know and when was like second classes
they were put out on the street or had
to move back home so they created
alimony to balance it out now women are
strong and independent can do everything
a man can do so why do you need alimony
you're admitting saying I need a debt I
need a man to help me raise this child
or live my life because I can't do it on
my own but nobody ever points that out
and child support is actually
unconstitutional because you never see
the government see when when you're
together and married
when you after you separate your rights
I just did a video on this on Instagram
who you are you don't unbecome the
father you're still the father so your
parental rights toward the kids are the
same the government never comes into
your family home and say okay you pay
the Victoria's Secrets bill you take the
trash out you spend time with the kids
tonight they can't come into your life
when you're intact but the government
snuck in and when they created a system
where when you break up they can all of
a sudden jump in and dictate your
domestic life with you and the system
was never intended to do that there's
all kinds of unconstitutional problems
with child support alimony and even the
family courts period
I'm like let's take out the kid
let's talk and I'm like YouTube bought a
dog together and would it make sense for
him to for her to take the dog and you
have to pay for it wouldn't it make
sense for the person that could afford
the dog to keep the dog now maybe
they're like don't compare children to
adults but it kind of shows how
ridiculous it is right yeah
give it to the parent that can
if you apply this to everything else
like say you get in a Business
Partnership and you guys are split you
got a million dollar business and you
split the profits or profited a million
and you have a contract that you agreed
to share everything and then you walk
away and one person gets everything and
the other person has to start over and
stuff like that and their resume gets
wiped out you know or you know they are
they're dinged with this is a corrupt
business partner because when a guy gets
a domest protection order that might
screw him on on on certain things in
life and not be able to get a job and
stuff like that too I have a theory
that it actually affects the average men
the most when this happens as opposed to
the high earners even though the wife
might like take more from the high
earners in like divorce and family court
because the high earners they're usually
really high IQ where they can recover
Jeff Bezos yeah his wife screwed him but
like the man isn't really hurting but
what I realized just from doing the
interviews that um the average men are
the ones that won't recover because
they've worked for 20 years they're not
the type of guy that can just like
rebuild that overnight start an online
business like they're gonna work this
job they've worked the last 20 years
yeah and the other thing yeah and so I
was like and sometimes I'll I'll hear
from like high earning men oh I don't
know why you can just rebuild you'll be
fine but I'm like I I believe like IQ
has different outcomes I know that's
like a different you know conversation
but but it's like I I think it affects
the average man and the most because he
can't just like recover like that
right and I think you're right too I had
a guy who he had when he got a hold of
me he already had he had to pay like 2
000 a month in child support and he
didn't have a job for a while because it
was during uh the bush bush years over
here when we had a recession and what he
did I can't remember we did then he got
a new job he was living in his truck in
order to pay child support because he
felt it was a noble thing to make sure
he paid child support and he went to
court to try and undo child support he
got a corrupt ruling and then I was
reaching out to him saying you know you
can appeal this or do a reconsideration
revision you got three four shots at it
and his uh his family called me and told
me he had killed himself after that
ruling so I yeah I've seen some cases
where guys they got a hold of me too
late now there may have been some other
problems going on I can't say for sure
that's a crazy coincidence that after
this ruling he's like he finally had
some hope because I'm showing him the
law and how it's Draconian over the top
and all stuff he had some hope and then
he lost again and before I had a chance
to tell him look it's not the end of the
world we need to go again and he he was
dead he was a middle class worker you
know these guys are moving back in with
their parents yeah they are the mother I
know guy I I know a case with this guy
the mom got a restraining order against
him and then she was going back over to
his house and manipulated him and have
sex with her and then when he went to
court to tell about that oh he's a
pervert because he was forcing her to
have sex she was coming over to his
house when she got a protection order
there I mean people would not you have
to show the most insane situations and
people to sit down and listen to him for
people the outside of family no
everybody outside of Family Court
doesn't realize how bad it is when
you're in Family Court people like oh my
God how come nobody's doing anything
about this and then when they're done
and burned out I say come along let's go
protesting and they don't want anything
to do with it so the system never
changes
when it comes to the most vicious women
I've noticed a trend and I'm just
curious if this is lined up with what
you see because I just noticed like
patterns it's always women between the
ages of like 25 to like 32 33 roughly
and there's always an unplanned
pregnancy within the first like year
year and a half of them being together
and so the guys often time will marry
her do the right thing and then she kind
of screws him like
one to two years after the kid
yeah
um
I've seen the whole gamut so I can't
really pinpoint that but I I've Seen It
All I've seen people getting divorced in
their mid-40s and the woman is trying to
get his retirement and I actually had a
co-worker who said you know I gotta wait
five more years before I probably get
divorced I'm like why do you say that
she goes because I he needs to be vested
in his retirement before I get take half
of it I'm like you're crazy like how do
you even admit that to a co-worker but
I've seen the whole you know probably
some of the craziest things I've seen is
when and there's an out of wedlock child
and
um and I don't I don't prove it having
kids out of wedlock I I did it myself I
did it the wrong way I Didn't Do It
God's way Nature's order and that type
of stuff but when that happens and the
dude gets a new girlfriend or moves on
that that that can go crazy and
manipulate him and use that child as a
weapon against him which is a form of
child abuse as far as I'm concerned
that's probably some of the most common
things I deal with is younger the first
time around
um and the woman just uses the child to
control the guy because it's in a
woman's Nation to want to control a guy
I actually if anybody else out there
who's a Bible believer the curse of Eve
is having pain and labor but the second
curse is that her desire is to rule over
the man whether you believe in that or
not it's a crazy coincidence that women
repeal the 19th stop listening to women
right she's the 19th right and you know
like you know there's that hashtag
believe her and and all this stuff where
you just automatically believe and it's
a natural thing you know the woman is
the weaker sex it's a natural thing to
want to protect a woman and especially
guys the average guy thinks a guy's a
punk if he beats up a woman so we're on
the same side supposedly of what
feminists are on the side of but they
vilify the entire gender because once
when when women's suffrage happened they
wanted equality it's something like you
always talk about something went a whole
other level they don't want equality you
give them an inch they want to take a
parsec well and the suffrage it's like
we're not popular there was hundreds of
thousands of women they wrote lists of
like why they did not want to vote and
like why women would ruin doing this
like 100. Andrew Tate makes a great
point and there's other people who said
it they wanted women in the workforce so
they could have they could tax a home
twice and women bought it and actually
there's a great theory that the women's
suffrage movement came along women's
rights came along to help distract from
the civil rights movement because there
are people who didn't want black
families to remain strong and intact and
80 percent of kids born of a black
father were in the in a marriage and
here comes women's suffrage and let's be
strong and independent and they hand out
welfare like like candy and then these
women just chased after government
cheese like it was more important than
their child's welfare of having a father
and boom here we are you know so
um well why don't you tell the people
where they can find you um I know you
said or I think you you said earlier
just how how I got custody right yeah if
you type in the hashtag whatever your
whatever your favorite I I'm on I'm on
Tick Tock Instagram and YouTube I have a
website how I got custody.com but all
all my stuff is Consolidated into my
flow page so if you type in how I got
custody in the word flow you'll get to
my flow page all my resources are in a
nice uh or organ kind of organized
fashion where they're all in one place
but I've had guys who watched my video
and got full custody just watching my
video and absorbing my free stuff so I'm
not here just hustling guys like these
attorneys and uh you know you know I'm
I'm trying to get the word out and the
hope that you can win if I did it and
thousands other guys have done it
anybody could do it well thank you so
much for coming on
um I think this is great so thank you so
much I appreciate the work you're doing
thank you I appreciate you having me on
thank you very much
um guys make sure um you like the video
on your way out uh subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
um make sure you go visit his page I
really want to get you on some debates
like virtual ones I have some ideas of
like some people I think would be really
funny to have you on yeah I'm not hard
to find so all right guys like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time